الفاكهه الاشهر في جازان في جنوب السعوديه
يبدا هذه الايام حيث يجني المزارعون الاف
الاطنان لنشرها في السوق المحلي او
لتصديرها مليون شجره مانجو في جازان وفق
اخر الاحصائيات ومنذ انطلاق النسخه الاولى
من مهرجان المانجو السنوي تنتج ما يزيد عن
65 الف طن سنويا
من صبيا في جيزان ينضم الينا مراسل
العربيه عبد الرحمن العصيمي حياك الله عبد
الرحمن وحيا الله الصبيه
وريحه صبيا ومنجا صبيا ومانجا جيزان في
اصناف جديده الموسم
طبعا خالد احنا بين ارضكم وجمهورك انا
اعرف انت يعني حجم حبك وشوقك المنطقه
جيزان وفعلا جيزان منطقه يعني تعشق جدا
وخاصه بها وكما قال الشاعر مثل صبيا في
الغواني ما تشوف ففعلا كل شيء هنا جميل
وغاني ومتميز وعلى راسها طبعا خالد
المانجو المانجو الذي بدات زراعته من
السبعينات ميلاديه بعد ان تم جذب بعض
الاشجار من دوريه مصر العربيه الى جيزان
ونجح نجاح مبهر وبدا يزيد مع الوقت طبعا
بعض المزارع بدات بالجني من شهر مارتش
الماضي والان ايضا بدا الجني في هذه
المزرعه الموجوده على تخوم صبيا سادع
زميلي ناصر ياخذ لكم بعض اللقطات الان هذا
المزارع كما نشاهد يبدا بجني المانجا بهذه
الطريقه
العصا بالضبط نعم وهذا لونه غريب يا خالد
لانه بنفسجي
اخضر مع شويه اصفر فمميز جدا هذا اللون
طبعا اذا ما تحدثنا خالد عن عدد الاشجار
فعلا الاشجار تجاوز عددها تقريبا اكثر من
مليون شجره جيزان كانت تنتج في عام 2005
18 الف طن سنويا لكن العامل الماضي وصل
الانتاج الى 65 الف طن وهذا رقم كبير جدا
ومن ضمن مستدافات رؤيه 2030 ان يزيد العدد
اكثر فاكثر خلال السنوات القليله المقبله
طبعا هناك مركز الابحاث الزراعيه التابع
لوزاره الزراعه هذا المركز يقوم ايضا بجهد
كبير مع المزارعين خالد لزياده ثقافتهم
الزراعيه وايضا محاوله زراعه انواع جديده
يعني من المتوقع ايضا الموسم هذا خالد
نشوف المشمش نشوف انواع اخرى من الفواكه
الاستوائيه لان اجواء جيزان تقريبا مشابهه
للاجواء الاستوائيه في جزر الشرق اسيا
وايضا جنوب افريقيا طبعا هناك ايضا برامج
يعني كثيره تقوم بها وزاره الزراعه مع
المزارعين لمحاوله تقديم الابحاث
والدراسات المفيده لهم وتحليل ايضا التربه
والمياه لتحديد خالد ما هي التربه
المناسبه وغير المناسبه حقيقه خالد جيزان
فيها قصه نجاح كبيره للزراعه مو بس مانجو
خالد حتى البوني شراكه مع ارامكو وايضا
شركات من قطاع الخاص نجحت ايضا في زراعتها
في فيفا والدائر ومناطق اخرى نشاهد هذه
المزرعه الان هذه المانجا خالد اشوف اربع
انواع او تقريبا اربع الوان اذا صح
التعبير اكثر من نوع طبعا ممكن نبدا على
اليسار هذا هو الزبده استعدادا
اول واحد الزبده والثاني خالد انا انا
بختبرك يا خالد
صحيح صحيح التومي والثالث الاصفر هذا
الاصفر هذا السوداني
يا خالد
السوداني طبعا هو في اسماء يا خالد في
اسماء علميه زراعيه وفي اسماء جيزانيه هي
الاربعه انواع هذه المشهوره حاليا
واللي بتجيب لنا انت منها كم كرتون
الانواع طبعا تقريبا اكثر
بس انت الحين انت في المزرعه انت الان في
المزرعه لازم انت مو انت طالع من المزرعه
كم كرتون ما راح نسامحك فيها
انا حجيب لك النوع هذا ابشر من عيوني
ولا لا حتى الشباب يعني ودوهم في مانجا
الجيزاني ما يتفوت لا طعم ولا ريحه ولا
نبي
ابشر ابو عبد الله نبي 15 كرتون للشباب في
الرياض خلاص
لا تخاف يا عبد الرحمن انا عارفك ههه اعرف
الفلوس حارسل لك رقم حساب
تامر امر خلاص بس قولي اذا في اذا في يعني
هذه الانواع اللي احنا تعودنا عليها في
جيزان الاربعه انواع لكن مدري هل في اصناف
جديده في هالسنه ممكن تدخل
السوق اتذكر زمان كان مثلا فيه المانجا
الصغار حبات الصغير اللي زي منقل فص في
مصر فما ادري اذا كان من ضمن الاصناف اللي
ممكن نشوفها في في الاسواق سنه
مثل هذه الزراعات زي ما قلت المانجو
الصغيره او البيبي او البيبي مانجو كما
يسمونه بعض المزارعين هذا المانجو مزارع
قليله تقوم بزرعته هنا في صربيا يحتاج الى
دراسات معينه طبعا اغلب المزارع هنا يعني
حتى طريقه الزراعه طريقه التقليديه
المعتاده لكن مثل الزراعات الخاصه
والمحميات الخاصه والانتاجات الخاصه
موجوده ببعض المزارع لكن الان بدات تنتشر
بالشراكه مع وزاره الزراعه بحيث انه
يشجعون المزارعين على زراعه انواع خاصه من
المانجو وايضا انواع اخرى من الفواكه خالد
سيما الفواكه الاستوائيه التي هي اقرب
انواع الفواكه واكثرها مناسبه للتربه في
جيزان لكن
المثير للانتباه خالد انه المزارعين هنا
يعني لديهم زي ما نقول افق واسع وتقبل
للانواع الجديده بالعكس يحبون يجربون
ويفضلون انه الوزاره تقترح عليهم انواع
جديده من المانجا
طبعا هذا المانجو حقكم يا خالد العربيه
بعد هذا هذا هذا عبد الرحمن هذا عبد
الرحمن
مو يروح يعني يلف كل مكان في السعوديه ولا
يجيب المشهد والمانجا ما يتفوت اذا وصلت
صعبه كثير ما تجي منك لا لا ان شاء الله
حنا بعد اليوم يا خالد بعد قليل حنروح
نفطر ان شاء الله مع صاحب المزرعه الشيخ
يحيى
حنفطر فطور جيزاني ان شاء الله وحنحلي
طبعا وفطور وجيزاني شعبي
كل الاكلات الجيزانيه طبعا خالد هذا نوع
حجمه عجيب وكبير صراحه
يعني تقريبا اكبر من كف اليد بالضبط فحجمه
كبير صار
عبد الرحمن
شهيتنا قبل الفطور الله يهديك يلا جيب معك
بس كم كرتونه تعال لا تنسانا شباب مستنين
حتى شاهد المتروك بعد جلسه طالع شكرا لك
من صبيه في جيزان مراسل العربيه عبد
الرحمن شكرا